bella tutti ragazzi benvenuti a questo
nuovi dio sono fa vj oggi sono seduto
nella sala d'attesa o c'è anche marco
macina e c'è anche mark che non è lo
scheletro e colori fianco
ragazzi siamo sul secondo dsc pm l'altra
per capire come funzionava oggi qua
siamo dentro questo che cos'è del
tecnicismo e una speciale fabbrica
quando si ha un manicomio manicomio
abbandonato una mani come abbandonato
c'è un infermiera ciao ragazzi io
teletrasportatevi perché voglio mettervi
alla prova favi sì davvero bello era
diventato rosso deportati in questo
manicomi abbandonato per mettermi alla
prova e alla fine di tutto troverete un
scp molto speciale
vediamo se riuscite ad arrivarci ci
serve la carta di livello 1 esatto e
dobbiamo trovare qua dentro
secondo me si è qua dentro che ti
aspetta guardate che sherlock e che sono
non è che magari qua dentro ragazzi
domani a cera non c'era una cesta che
non avevo visto allora fatevi vedere
non però detto ho trovato della carne
con scritto fj grazie mille rumor vaio e
non presento niente ma io sono magro con
due piste che mi lazio comunque qua
dietro c'è una macchina del capo una
macchina che io me la ricordo benissimo
marco te la ricordi questo la macchina è
un scp la macchina è un e se si viva è
una macchinetta del caffè stupendi che
sia la macchinetta e allora se una gold
e come funziona con i gol di chi sceglie
gold sono in giro allora cerchiamo i gol
di fermi tutti
c'è un buco è realtà mediamente c'è un
buco ma non le so capire se c'è una
busta c'è un accesso momento la ragazza
csc un buco c'è una ciste nascosta
dietro la ces
eccola levelone keyboard o troppo ma
vale oro si lo giuro ho preso il gol del
non metto la macchinetta
buongiorno a te mi ha dato un pesce
amata del cibo ok mila del ciclo credo
in cambiare loro mi dà del pesce mazzo
usiamo la roba di ripa prino apri fi
voglio passare perfetto non fanno una
prova non apre ma non ho capito ma chi
cavolo giura ragazzi va bene va bene e
non so le mani morte io sono né
sensibili realtà non lo sapete non ho
trovato che se la natura fermi tutti
anche qua ce n'è uno ok per tutti altro
tutti seriamente ma per tutti noi stiamo
ridendo ma veramente inquietante è pieno
di scherma alcuni signori è bellissimo
ragazzo sto computer qua funziona mai
cup
no il defibrillatore d'altra parte stai
fatevi contraria istanza e magari ci
sono cose di nascosto qualcosa di
nascosto quando c'è store e pantaloni
distribuisco io ma due perfetto tieni
queste ce n'è una scollatura presidio li
ho presi io per voi ragazzi però la mia
domanda è una incontriamo un scp oche
che siamo vestiti bene gucci però
dobbiamo difenderci ma a sc pt 0 49 così
lo 0 49 ragazza lag doctor dovrebbe
essere esatto che sarebbe quello già
bene sia esatto cioè quello che toglie
la peste chi da poison mi sa che puoi
guardarlo debole consociare infatti di
qua di quando sa che poi sbircia riesce
a sbirciare
ad ali el altra stanza puoi sbirciare
vivere andiamo o mio dio è proprio
piaciuto riguarda ok se vi sarà che
orribile io non lo vedo però vede le sue
cavie sono lì perché non l'ha visto
l'avessero visto nell'angolino
si va via raggirato sembra tipo un film
dell'orden non farci vedere perché ci
ammazza quindi anche se ci ammazza carta
del livello 3 per altro serve ardizio le
regalo un pezzo d'oro faccio qualche
sicuro i tagli un pezzo d'oro è sia ma
magari mese ma mi ha visto come ti ha
visto come ti ha visto sta verificando
che avanza di vedere è vero
mamma mia è orribile orribile vabbè
lasciamo lì c'è una pistola quadrino
ristoro per eleonora ragazzi prendi
prendi pistola piccone e un visore
notturno ci ha addirittura mamma mia
ragazza ecco è vero ma che pirla può
fare o di vederla si può sempre qua
prova la prima pensa te la fa aprire lo
permette
non lo so c'è una pecora è un esigibili
no non lo lascia lì sigillerà quarta
cattiva e divisori me televisore o mio
dio che ansia silenzio attorno
per i tagli di amia ce li avevi
completamente intorno vedo delle robe
anche da qua vedo messa delle robe anche
da qua solo che l'isola notturno allora
le vedo che senso
ma vacanze c'è tipo un rossetto
all'inizio della stanza e ho fatto una
roba orribile sento rumori strani
ragazzi sentono rumori strani attenzione
io controllerei questa stanza qua c'è
una bambola dove mamma mia quanto krypi
perché controllo che ci siano stati gli
slip killer quando la bambola è questa
bambola è peggiore del teddy che c'è qua
davanti obiettivo quindi bisogna ora c'è
un'altra arma ci capita sulla pistola
io ne ho due già senza problemi guarda a
caso e mi è venuto in mente guarda i
film è una freccia è vero che pirla
entro
ma dai ma com'è possibile va bene che
c'è una password
ma cominciamo a pazzo c'è una password
no avrebbe ragazze una password prova
tipo 11100 stesse aspetta aspetta
proprio quella del mio canale ma 0000
funzionano 0 0 0 ma come bacheche
manicomio stupido li veltri card abbiamo
la testa riversa le ragazzine si può
abbiamo cercato tutte roche grande
password non mi sarebbe mai venuto in
mente queste minacciando qua comunque ci
sono dei piani di sopra e andiamo a
vedere voi andare a vedere prima del
doctor prima magari fino al doctor o
cavagnolo al doctor loro oppure i
ragazzi dovete essere veramente pronti
aspetto magari non c'era 3
bye bye è rimasto solo lui attenzione
rientrate marcate se l'aspetta
ciao mamma mia come la polizza
siamo veramente degli amici pessimi
aveva la dobbiamo spiegare perché se non
si capisce questa cosa se qualcuno tipo
isola cioè il dottore diventi che si
crea uno zombie col tuo nome noi
volevamo vedere disse muoversi ragazzi
però io non ho una chiave per venire da
voi cosa faccia mi guardava io arioso
saluto sulla sedia comunque no ragazzi
ho aperto qualcosa ma vi giuro non so
che cosa aspetta a è vero dimmelo 4
dentro una cera la stessa la tessera
sotto la sedia alla non l'avrei mai
trovato ma mi sono ospita cliccato a
casa presso esame va bene quindi cosa
facciamo andiamo su prima casa che
figata via occhiali slip killer ragazzi
che un casino
chi paga o mio dio riproviamo ma loria
ma perché c'è un libro mafia per chi
proprio non te lo vorrei dire di non lo
apro io sono stato ma c'è una mentre 47
va bene non mi dire che non mi avete
ragazzi ho ringraziato il libro così
l'ho firmato nel mentre è 49 perfetto
già tutta la passione e te ne stai link
e calma siamo siamo un attimino calmi
per favore perché è signor noi l'abbiamo
già affrontato ed è grande perché se
disparate roba il problema che lui shot
ok nel messico non c'è
è dentro è dentro la cabina abbiamo
nausea perché un audio lo so anche io è
rimasto finotti grazie ragazzi io ho
nausea o o ansia o week neanche mai
stato degli delle robe orribili non
capisco diamo alla finestra ma è colpa
delle sc p
ma non è mai successo sta guarda le
scuole che ha spaccato il vetro io li ho
trovati a parigi in compenso allora
adesso ti spiego come funziona
tecnicamente questo gp qui haring dentro
a una gaiola non c'e nessun permesso
posso fosse raga non c'e nessuno è un
bait significa mi fate entrare su inter
permesso grazie fermi dai piccone per
favore che io ho tutto tutto è rinchiuso
dentro a questo blocco e allora è pronto
a guardarlo allora se una cosa non
guardarlo in faccia
c'è guarda tipo un po vicino esatto ok e
devi spaccare anche questo perché vedo
sue braccine occhio a chiamarci attento
siamo attenti a dare come dire non si
deve arrabbiare
allora ho chiesto chi è che la click
erato io non l'ho guardato in faccia
vorrai per terra no ragazzi è colpa di
marco ciao ragazzi è stato bello mi
piaceva chiare violenza non è mai in
turno non dovrebbe poter spaccare il
ferro ok
mia ragazza madonna che casino io ho una
riga di otto effetti rai aiuto
lasciamo arrabbiare ragazzi sarebbe
mamma mia che brutta orribile allora
facciamo così via per questo ok siete
pronti a sparare io apro per favore
sparategli va bene vai ad avere una
pistola
incredibile guardate occhio mammamia
ricaricare devo ricaricare
ma non muore mai c'è la vita incredibile
e morto non è morto amore allora volta
la tua porta york a tokyo ha rotto la
porta ma non è vero come prezzi non vi
giuro non è impossibile che amava che un
limbo massimo ragazzi però per favore un
po più organizzati perché ho capito lo
ha sfondato tutto attenzione che posso
andare per questa sarà la mia bella e
può fare tutto è permesso
mi ricordo una cosa potrebbe esserci la
possibilità che sia un scp modificato e
con la possibilità che non muoia che non
è un scp normale che hai detto vado io
dai vai
ok ma sta dormendo adesso ragazzi stato
il mondo sta dormendo ma allora facciamo
così
poi tornando di vermeer e mette evidente
chiedetelo esatto chiudi guarda e non
possiamo tipo conciso di prenderle
blocco lisa di fuoco
ragazzi io ho mezza caricatore di
pistola profitto è andiamo via
marche carroccio quella fare lì
mi sta dormendo a lui non gliene frega
niente occhio si è svegliato e mori
mamma mia ragazzi casinò sta urlando mi
piace non urla amore l'amore mai basta
occhio maledizione mori non muore
economia
raccoglieremo
un miliardo di colpi non bada immortale
e immortala mentre facciamo che i cavoli
suoi
la porta non esiste più hanno veramente
sfondata comunque secondo me io ti posso
dire una cosa all'interno e ci è voluto
far vedere questo scp perché comunque
era già stato visto e rivisto le sue cp
0 96 è questo qui è diverso dagli altri
perché perché è immortale e quindi un
civile simile e la cosa mi dà veramente
fastidio perché la prima scp 96 che veda
90 segreto e che invincibile ma
l'elezione volevo ucciderlo comunque
torneremo perché impossibile dovremo
trovare un modo per uccidono il secondo
me c'è solo che dobbiamo trovarlo
ragazzi ragazzi spero che il video vi
sia piaciuto fatemi sapere se volete
altri video su di esse cp marce marco e
io spero che le sc pizza 96 trovi il
modo di morire perché lo deve cercare
anche lui ci deve aiutare però vi sia
piaciuto
cliccate anche la campanella per
rimanere aggiornati sui prossimi video
passate anche le rive dei canali ragazzi
descrizione e noi come sempre ci vediamo
l'anno prossimo visto
[Musica]